let's get more now on Russia's
announcement that it is planning to pull
out of the International Space Station
after
2024 to discuss exactly what this means
I'm joined by Dr Martin Archer a space
physicist at Imperial College London
good to see you this afternoon thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
ah you're welcome
um now this was an entirely unexpected
news but what do you think the reasoning
is behind the decision for Russia to to
pull out of the International Space
Station
I mean I just want to say this is very
disappointing news to be honest um this
is a collaboration that's been going on
well will it been going on for more than
25 years by the time they pull out at
the end of 2024. now obviously political
situations over that time have changed
and it's managed to be maintained that
the current situation there's been a lot
of threats threats have happened in the
past but it seems like this is a lot
more serious
um and I don't know exactly why they've
decided now to take that stance
um to might to me personally and to a
lot of colleagues who work in the space
sector uh the collaboration across many
many different uh countries in the ISS
has been more about more than politics
it's been about science engineering
human achievement and to see politics
get in the way
um it's really quite sad yeah you talk
about the different nations and that
operate um on the International Space
Station and collaborate explain to us
what nations are involved and what
Russia's country distribution is because
you describe this as as disappointing
and of course it will be one when one
nation you know leaves a collaboration
but talk to you how it operates and the
actual practical effects of what's
Happening
sure so
um the main contributors are of course
uh you've got NASA over in the U.S
there's the Canadian space agency the
European Space Agency the the UK is a
part of and that's how Tim P got to go
up to the International Space Station
um and then um Ross Cosmos which is the
Russian space agency now they played
quite a large role
um in the International Space Station
there are Russian modules on board and
since the space shuttle was
decommissioned they have been the
primary way of astronauts getting up
there using soyuz capsules
um now we do have capability now uh with
private companies such as SpaceX to to
send astronauts up to the International
Space Station without the involvement of
Russia
um but they've been a crucial part of
this collaboration for its entirety
um and so there were really key partners
and you you hope that that collaboration
would continue and in fact plans for
future space stations you know we were
hoping that we could probably even have
collaboration with China and do
something even more amazing than we've
been able to do with the ISS but you
know news like this doesn't doesn't bode
well for that sort of idea yeah Russia
has said it will fulfill its commitments
until 2024 as agreed they're then going
to go on their own build their own space
station and other than the Grandeur and
the Kudos are doing something like that
is it beneficial for Russia to go it
alone and or what detriment does it have
to the work that's done on the
International Space Station
well I think all of these things end up
being greater than the sum of the parts
so the more people you can get involved
the the greater the outcome is you know
space is is not an easy thing to do it's
uh it's expensive but when you have many
many nations that have huge gdps it
becomes actually very very achievable
and not as expensive as just doing it on
your own and so that's really why we've
been moving away from doing things just
as one nation and and collaborating
internationally to achieve much greater
things so I it seems like a backward
step I can see why politically Russia
are saying they want to do that but I I
don't see that as as the right way
forwards for for what we're all trying
to achieve with space here yeah back on
planet Earth they're pretty tough times
I mean you reference the political
situation uh the war in UK crane we're
talking about drought next month in the
UK we're talking about cost of living
crisis there are so many different
factors going on at the moment the
climate emerges see is there still the
appetite for what is happening on the
International Space Station are the
budgets there are governments invested
or is it something you can see
sort of being pushed to the side in the
future given what we're dealing with as
I said here on planet Earth right now
well you know the International Space
Station is not actually that far away
you know you look up you can see it in
the night sky it's it's only a couple of
hundred kilometers up it's closer than a
lot of our country uh partners and what
it allows us to do is see that bigger
picture of our world
um and actually you know combat a lot of
these kind of things you know a lot of
climate evidence comes from space space
is a hugely invaluable tool to tackle
all of the problems that we're facing
and the budgets in terms of an overall
Nations budgets that go into even just
science and research which you know is
everything is is really quite small
compared to other areas that we put
money in and in this science that allows
Nations to progress find Solutions and
that it could potentially solve a lot of
these problems so it's so important that
we have that investment even if it's so
little and even at times a time you know
we don't put that much into it but we
get a huge reward from it in the long
term uh your case very well argued that
Dr Martin arches space physicist at
Imperial College London good to talk to
you thank you